Take care by Madeline Rosenberg.
Illustrated by Juliana Gregory.
Take care of the world, of the mountains and trees.
Tend to the world all the bumbles and bees.
Color the world with greens and with blues.
Light up the world with the words that you choose.
Hope for the world through the storms that may come.
Help heal the world with Te Kun O Lam.
Reach out to the world,
to the big and the small.
Share the wide world.
It belongs to us all.
Te Kuno Lam, Hebrew for repairing the world,
is a fundamental Jewish value,
not to mention a lifelong intergenerational project.
According to the Torah,
the first five books of the Bible,
God created the world in six days,
but gave human beings the task of helping care for it.
The world is a wondrous place,
but it is also a work in progress.
It is everyone's job to pitch in and make it even better.
As Rabbi Tarfone,
a first century sage, said,
it is not your responsibility
to finish the work of perfecting the world,
but you are not free to desist from it either.
Repairing the world may feel like a very big job,
but it can be tackled with many small acts.
The famous 20th century Rabbi
Abraham Joshua Hessles
message to young people was that every little deed counts,
every word has power.
Even little kids can take part into Kuno Lam.
Whether we pick up a piece of litter on The sidewalk
pause to make sure a turtle crosses the road safely,
or offer a kind word to a new classmate.
Every one of us can help care for our planet and its inhabitants,
all its bumbles and bees every day.